okay
are we live
hello
hello
music so epic
how we doing this morning
what up people
good aye good day good day
hope everyone is doing good
welcome good to have you here
sakira
what's up bibs
hey glenn how you doing man
uh double
howdy howdy
thank you for the good luck
esther
how are you
yeah i had a little bit of time to kind
of do whatever so i thought i might as
well stream for a little bit see how it
goes
what's up stan good to see you
some of us are playing elden ring some
of us are working and you jake are doing
both
that's true this is my job
which is kind of cool i like that
i like that bro so i guess we were doing
ronnie
the ronnie quest she's asleep
yeah she's done so
can i
can i attack her here
oh
you can wake her up
and it will be some time before i wait
no idea you could do that
i look forward to the good news when i
arise
first time i've done that
you can just wake her up
hey she didn't kill me
i have seen that clip though where she
will delete you
like just end your life
that was so surprising though okay so
we've done the first part of ronnie
which means
oh no
you all know what that means now huh
we gotta we gotta go to caitlin
we gotta go to caled
we gotta go uh beat up radon
oh boy
i'm gonna let it be daytime
hi silly how are you
hello piggy
what
god
caleb scares me but it is cool
caleb's a cool place
kayla's a hard area man you're brave to
just go there
as a starting area
it's definitely not designed to be a
starting area that's for sure
we're going to hell guys
we're going to hell
dude i love in uh from software games
that they show you like we can see
all the way up there to the flame of the
giants from down here i think that's
sick
and we can go up there
that's like the best part of this game
for me
i feel like i never got that feeling in
in every other game i've played
oh yeah we got this lady
can i just stab her in the back right
here
what up yoda what up
well i messed up the stabby
get out of here
dead
what i miss nothing we just started
what's up sir killington
what do you think about clean rot night
armor
uh what do i think about it it's cool
it looks pretty neat
those are um
melania's
like warriors right
yeah yeah yeah
i have not done anything yet yoda
we decided to go to caleb that's all
i've done oh i also smacked ronnie in
the face and i woke her up
she didn't kill me though which is cool
thank you silly
i'm glad you uh
liked the last video
i got a new video coming out this
weekend
i'm excited about it too i think it's
really good
new video is
i'm happy with it i just recorded all
the narration like the voice over
this morning and now i just need to edit
the [ __ ] out of it
holy saturated red
what up boys
yeah we got to go to radon
there's the tower
what do you get from this
world of flame
we're a flame
oh god
i'll thank you luis
i am loving it i'm having a great time
with this game
i appreciate this game very much
been waiting for this game my whole damn
life
the hell was that
oh
you know just people on fire
flame
of the red mains for poise break
that does sound pretty cool
that sounds like a pvp thing though
not huge on pvp
but i know a lot of people are
okay so we could do uh let's see
we should probably start with millicent
right
probably let's go this way
yo what up trey how we doing today
go to our girl millicent
you killed radon we're about to do that
hopefully
nice dude that's big
you are you are in it now
do you like the fight
the radon fight is my favorite
for me personally
what's your favorite boss fight chat
you could do any of them what's your
favorite one
oh you went early then you went in the
castle early
about the show like uh you can go into
that castle and nobody attacks you
if you go in at the right time
your mom
but malaka yeah malcot this is cool
dragon lord is great
yup godric soldier
godric soldier
the hardest fight in the game
ludex gundyr
would you guys be interested in like a
playthrough of another
like uh from software game like if we
played like bloodborne or sakiro dark
souls 3 on stream that'd probably be fun
i can run through dark souls 3 in like
four hours
i could do that for a stream one day
where am i
oh here we go
sure okay sweet
not that i don't want to stop playing
elden ring but
those games are quite good on their own
as well
godskin apostle is still my hardest boss
i i don't know why i say apostle apostle
yeah very
i mean it gets easier
just wait to find a the fat one
once you see the fat one
that's gonna be tough
bloodborne is lit however uh
i don't know about you guys but playing
a game in 30 frames per second is not
the best experience ever
the fat one's the noble
yeah gundyr is sick dude
melania's best boss or malacath
well i wasn't asking what's the best
boss i'm saying uh asking what's your
personal favorite
i will probably not play dark souls 2
on on stream
i played through that game once and did
not like it
i mean i could for the memes i don't
care we could do it could be like an
interesting stream
yo mama oh wait i need to turn up
everything
if you are wise you will leave
immediately
i need to turn up the voices
it is a curse
dark souls remastered at 60. yeah we
could play dark souls i have the
remastered version
we could do that
why do i have this on
damage negation probably for
uh your girl
ranala i think it's when we use it
raises max i mean whatever um
what was i doing i was gonna raise the
sound
a blue
that's all okay
so she is bugging
absolutely bugging out
we gonna go this way
um
jumping down there without dying is
really hard so we're actually gonna go
this way
if i get down here we don't even need to
open the gate in celia
just get down over here
what the heck
we'll take it i guess
where am i going right here
i've never played neo is it good
we're golden
what's up bub
demon souls remastered i have yet to get
a ps5
i don't know how anyone could possibly
even get one now
so
no clue
oh god we're gonna have to beat the
general aren't we
honestly i find radon easier to beat
than the general out here
i could just find them on my horse
though
walmart
yeah
they're definitely available at walmart
i felt the elden beast was too easy as
an in-game boss cinematically was my
definitely my favorite i think it was
meant to be that
just a cinematic ending
i thought radagon was like a perfect
final boss but eldon beast was kind of
sussy vodka
uh this could be kind of
kind of bad guys
i don't like fighting this guy
make them bleed though
yeah i know the the strat of the arrow
damn it
yup that's why oh god
nice try
bruh
cut it out
gotcha
i got the bleed
not what i wanted to do
for safety for safety avi hobby
get out of there
run
uh whatever you want to do trey either
one works
oh god
i was looking at chat
it does the same thing
selling's faster
there it is
that's what we wanted
[Music]
yeah yeah
i got stunned
and insta died
that was going so well
oh my god
that was going so well
and it just all dot it just ended so
fast
we go again
dude do the move
come on
oh i didn't have any stamina
get in there
okay
have you tried throwing your axe
is that ever gonna die
that meme
that god of war meme
have you tried throwing your axe
all right i just wanted to bleed we got
it there it is
okay
they announced new stuff for the game
where
let me move
[Music]
we
leave me alone dude
get off his left side
they're all hugging his left side
this is where i can actually hit him
uh oh it's over we died
okay
leave me be
what does this moment mean or mor morbin
right what is morbin
i saw that on twitter
hmm
stay over there stay over there
dang it
a jared leto movie
okay okay this is it
wait
wait
bruh
oh god
one
there it is
that went that went better than the last
one
nice
kill the minions
no
i didn't need to clearly
sir
bigger
leveling vigor
it's my birthday and i just got the best
present ever my wife took the kids on a
three-hour road trip
on your birthday
that sounds like a great present
happy birthday man
where am i going
what am i doing
i don't know
i'm going this way i don't want to deal
with the dog
uh yes this
crazy weirdo
oh a pleasure to see you oh a pleasure
to meet you sonny a great sage sorry
anyway
i'd hoped to ask a favor when one of
your ilk came along
a strapping young tarnished able to
cross the scarlet swamp while they only
ear
don't uh oh i'll provide fine did the
internet die should you accept uh-oh
teach you the secret of celia the town
you see there chat
i think we're lagging we're lagging
oh my god
oh
what happened
[Music]
oh god
are we live right now hello
hello
all right my internet just
destroyed itself
you all hear me
it's normal to me uh my my obs just
crashed heavy okay i think we're i think
we're still here
all right i think we're here
get morbed
you heard my windows
yeah
all right well at least we're here ah
then you are willing to lend a hand are
you i think
all right let me know if we're back
i don't know what's going on
can you hear me
oh my neighbors are leeching yeah
exactly
exactly dude
i think we're good all right thank you
yeah i
obs sometimes dude is just like uh i
don't feel like it i don't want work
right now
oh yeah
yeah you found the unalloyed gold needle
as promised i've detailed the secret of
celia right here
go on
it's yours
you mean the secret i already know about
gallery let me have a look at the needle
have a good one kyle
well well this is a marvel indeed
the work of a true artist it's going vip
ridiculous bold craftsmen who grasp this
it's going to take a while sense of life
can you give me some time i mean i
restarted obs killington well made as it
is it won't be much use snapped in half
will it seems to be working though
usually it'll crash and then uh
reconnect and it'll just give you a
delay but i don't even think we have a
delay now since i just fully reset it
ebenezer can you give me something yeah
yeah i'll give you some time with that
yeah yeah
i just go here
is that guy a secret admirer of
millicent he ha he has something to do
with um
birthing
like the
the sisters or clones of
millicent kind of hard to understand
i'm still looking into that myself
he calls them he's like their father
and if you go to the end of millicent's
questline there's like a bunch of them
there are four of them
including milson
yeah if you um i'm pretty sure i could
kill him right now and he'll just come
back right i have awaited your return
and he'll he'll uh be one of those weird
pests
i'm sure
will you give it to the girl millicent
i will reward you in kind
thanks
millicent rests at the church atop the
cliff beyond celia the town yonder yeah
he's like breeding millicent clones
it's like he's trying to make other
millennials
as a god
a wretched fate indeed
the poor girl she never wished for any
of this
like like if we ever thought why is
millicent
why does she have no arm exactly like
melania
like did this guy rip off her arm
did this have her be like melania i have
no idea
wouldn't be too weird in this freaking
weird world
if you are wise you will leave
immediately
my flesh writhes with scarlet trout
well yeah i don't think the rot just
like rips off your your limbs like that
it looks like his uh hold on
it looks like it was just it's just gone
it's
you know cut off
all the way up there none of our other
buddy body parts are missing
if you are wise you will leave
immediately
my flesh rides i mean he's a good guy
killington he's a good guy in his own
way you ask that i stabbed myself with
the needle
to quell the scarlet robbed
but
how
she cut it off herself
never mind
did you say that decided
i would rather trust you
than simply continue to spoil from
within
would you mind
averting your eyes for a moment
wonder why she makes us not look
can you give me a hand millicent
well
that was easier than expected
and she's out
monk all right
okay gideon off here
you're up i
hope to see you again
my apologies
for when last we met
i fainted before i could even thank you
everything is as you said
since inserting the needle the scarlet
rot has ceased to writhe
even the nightmares have abated
and now
though i can scarcely believe it myself
i can move as i please
not that i could ever truly repay you
imagine all the five melanias kill you
and say i'm melania blade of nicola
by way of thanks i am millennia
blade
of
mickelah yay more dexterity pogers
i mean why not right
i'm considering leaving
on a journey
with the needle buried in my flesh
i've started to recall
but dimly
dimly
it's all thanks to you
my name is millicent
i pray fate permits us meat again
too mommy chulo
me too
hold on sorry
though we
do people are asking for a netflix
adaptation of elden ring what do you
guys think of that you guys want a
netflix show of this of this game
or just a show
we've got her rocking him rolling i
think now
let's go grab this and
we can go to radon
no
got one no two nose one yes three nos
four no's
five no's
okay not netflix uh like any show
adaptation or movie
because netflix is too expensive now
it's kind of [ __ ] and their
content's bad
they have some good shows though
i canceled netflix i got the whole like
hulu thing
and i've been i've been loving my hulu
stuff
like i got hulu tv espn plus disney plus
all packaged into hulu it's great
no ads
yep
oh can't trust anyone with doing that
true
okay what if
um
miyazaki
was completely a part
of the process of making the show or
movie how about that
he was fully involved
and george rr martin
do you think the greater will is still
looking on the lands between
probably
or an aspect of it could be many
different worlds out there in space
we don't know
keep george out of it
have you seen game of thrones yes but
george didn't ruin game of thrones
oh also trey this is gonna piss you off
by the way check this out so trey said
he struggled throughout this entire
castle
to get to radon
um george rr martin didn't ruin it he
didn't write the last two seasons of the
show
where's my music
there it is
yeah he could have finished the books
but he didn't write those
endings um
[Music]
this place is sick dude
what a blight
yo yo yo
thought i might find you here
i must admit
yeah they're trying to find girls
we missed our meeting
but
it looks like you're still in one piece
say you must have heard by now oh [ __ ] i
didn't go to nocron hold ronnie's fate
that's okay
but once he's out of the way
it'll spring back into motion
so now
or i didn't go to the
demigod the river known as the strongest
underground
the way ahead is pleasingly simple
we fight
sword and fang
sword and fang
this chick works for uh celibus right
i think she does
yeah
champions
welcome
the stars of aligned
the festival is nigh
general completionist run is ruined i
didn't get every piece of dialogue
no
champions
prepare for battle
defeat the general
claim glory and grab that great have a
good one silly
a celebration of war
the
[Applause]
festival
[Music]
like how we all just don't care ah
you came how delightful
indeed i thought i might find you here
by the by do you know for whom this
festival is being held
well
it is none other than general radon
himself
i love alexander i could face a great
champion of the shattering this voice
acting for a giant pot is insane
in truth i quiver at the thought such is
his frightful repute
but
the fear simply assures me the shadow of
undertaking
be sure to get a good advantage my
friend
i
iron fist alexander
do hereby vow to unflinchingly brave
this ordeal
i
hereby vow
radon beat melania the their equals
thing is [ __ ] i don't think they're
equals
i think radon is stronger than melania
she had to unleash
basically a rot god to beat him and it
didn't even kill
let's get it
before we begin
allow me to paint you the full picture
oh my god he stuffed radon into himself
oh my god dude i didn't even think about
that
probably did yeah
that's crazy
general radar is cursed ever to wander
eaten from the inside by melania's
scarlet rot his wits are long gone
now he gathers the corpses of former
friends who phones alike
gorging on them
like a dog
i think from software would be stupid
not to make bloodborne 2.
[Music]
bloodborne 2 might sell just as just as
well as eldon ring
but now
we must make merry oh god he's going to
hit me with this thing
of champions
the rebels begin
the celebration of war
the redone festival
[Music]
right through my body
you will find the field of battle past
the church ahead oh my god can you
imagine an open world bloodborne game
dawn is there even now oh man
corpses
and howling at the sky
hey sony had all the rights to a god of
war as well but now that's on pc
let's do it
i think what level are we
50 it's kind of low for radon but we can
do it
we can do it fam we're good at this game
right we're pretty good pretty good at
the game
i don't think we need an open world
bloodborne too i in just bloodborne 2
would be awesome
elden ring was my first souls game i'm
slowly getting better well good
i mean just like everything you get
better at things like you're not going
to be good at it first time you play it
you know
yeah we got double katana so we're
looking pretty good here should i use
the summons or should i just fight on my
on my own
let's try on my own
come here daddy
now
where's my other sword
what happened
how did that even happen
dang it
ow
hey i like that
he should go into space
all right i got a theory after this
fight that i want to tell you guys about
now
i'm gonna die
whoa
leave me alone
no dude i was doing really good
you know the consequences of what you're
about to do slain this man will set in
motion world changing events
pretty much yeah
what content will you do after elden
ring the hype is dying so quickly i mean
it's really not this game is still
massively popular people are really
interested in the lore of it so
i don't know
do you think the spears on his back have
to do
our pre-melania or post well it's
definitely posts
uh because he doesn't have any
in the opening
in the trailer or the cut scene he
doesn't have anything on his back
all right let's summon our voice
oh god i summoned patches
worthless
i can't see
whoa that is fast
nice got him again
she's throwing pots at him now i don't
remember her doing that
have a good day luis
always comes down from the moon if you
look in that i guess you have to look in
the general direction
so not always from the moon
fly died
oh god
i think everyone's dead
no
[ __ ]
yeah this is still hard at level 50 man
we're close though
souls games have a fanatical following
you'll be good for content for a while
i'm i'm not worried about it currently
not worried about it
all is good
radon is baby mode in this patch you
know they reverted that right
like they made them easier and then they
uh tweaked them up a little bit
we
dude i hate that like shotgun shot he's
got
all right come at me bro
no he's not as dangerous as he was in
patch one no
wouldn't call him easy
freak
now
all right not a good run so far
got a bleed off
what's he doing the heck
man decided to ride in a circle
keep going
keep going boys
gee oh my god thank was that
i should get these
oh
leonard's revenge
there we go
there you go guys
i'll tell you my theory after this
after the cut scene
that was gg though we got really good
rng he just ran in a circle and we just
bled him out
yeah you can see mickelezer tree from
lots of different places yeah
yeah we almost uh first phased him that
would have been cool
i don't think i've ever done that before
bang
okay so you guys know that meteor right
we know
this this is my theory okay i i don't
have a ton of evidence for this
it's just what i think
so the meteor falls out of the sky and
obviously it opens up the the path to
nocron right but there are also like
lots of other stars coming out of the
sky right
so
we've been we've been trying to figure
out why radon has been holding this up
and there's lots of reasons for that but
one reason i think is
you know obviously him doing that stops
uh ronnie's quest line right we have to
beat radon so that he can drop the stars
and that she can continue her quest line
right
or her destiny for her ending
so you do you guys uh just before i go
any further do you guys know um the
ending area
of ronnie's quest line
which is at the church
here
or
wait
it's at a church somewhere up here
this is below this would be above so
it's this one
where you find ronnie underground
okay the game's been out three months so
i i don't i don't think i want to care
about spoilers
but she's in here at the end
spoil away i can't find anything
the two fingers
we find her with her two fingers down
there right that she kills
i think radon was holding that two
fingers in the sky and it crashed down
and created a crater right here that's
why there's that hole in the ground
where that two fingers was and then
ronnie went in to finish the job or it
was already dead
which i hadn't thought about till
recently
probably crashed down right here
that's where that's why all those
starlight shards are all over this place
i hadn't thought about it from that
perspective
ah good but radon was likely holding
back ronnie's
two fingers up there the glory of the
clash is shared
by radon
and you and then she killed her two
fingers with the finger slayer blade
a falling star right before our eyes
i can't fathom how radon was holding
back something of that scale
he was a living legend if ever i saw one
and the path has now been cleared
so radon was just holding her two
fingers in the sky crashed down and then
ronnie killed it with the two uh the two
finger blades the fingers played
for mistress ronnie
let's meet with a falling star why no
starlight shards at the no con entrance
i mean i don't know i don't know my only
purpose is to fight for ronnie's fate
sword and fan
the curtains rising
and the final act
why is the location of two fingers
landed called manacellus isn't that just
the name of the manor there let's meet
with the full church
it looks like a church to me
what's up octopus
can i jump on your head here alexander
just for like a weird
reason
oh god i bet i can do it
can i be consumed
it means celestial hand
nope oh
hello there
oh it was a battle marvelously forced
hello hello hello you are well have a
good one jars
i on the other hand
am nothing but a croc she took her two
fingers there
and for my insides to come i don't know
how she could do that after that i
wouldn't explain the crater in the
ground like a coward deep in the ground
i can hardly stand to face one such as
you
what's up yoda
but don't you think i've given up just
yet
as luck would have it there's a
veritable mountain of warriors bodies
right here
if i can just squeeze this bunch down
inside me i'll be a mine she's been
lifted in no time
and you know
the bodies found here are exceedingly
fine
who could expect any less from the very
warriors who fought in the shattering
the greatest of all wars
oh we're always lord hunting baby
friend i'll grow even stronger
just you wait when next we meet
did we find the singer finger slayer
blade and knock stella or nocron
uh no cron right the bodies found here
are exceedingly fine
who could expect any less from the very
warriors who fought in the shattering
the greatest of all wars
well i don't think the the two
the two fingers isn't dead she used this
finger slayer blade to kill it after it
crashed down to earth
have a good one bibs all right is it not
stella or no cron
i'm going to take you on a little
journey oh god i haven't heard that
inside me
and be part of me
you from now on
we're all in it together
so
let's all of us
dream big
ew that felt weird i have not heard him
say that before
whoa
[Music]
stella is mini ronnie so yeah it should
be nocron
okay
let's level up
got four levels that's huge that's big
that's big time
well we can always go and change this we
should pick
what we want to do
so hold on before i spend anything
do you guy so last stream we had the
idea of doing a radon build like just
wearing his armor and using his uh
his blades is that something you guys
want to do
because we can go to ranala and
switch up our character
if need be
why not i'm just
asking you guys
yeah radon's armor is pretty pretty cool
pretty neat
my
ew
but
my
look at you
only once before have i seen two great
runes together i don't think ronnie had
full control of the black knives at all
i don't think she had full control of
them
and what they do
they worked for her for a time but i
don't think she had like
total control over everything
you'll be slow as [ __ ] yeah but i'll
have radon school swords and an audience
with queen america
to become the
lord
could do the ruins great sword that is a
cool one too
but radon build could be fun
take this
a token of farewell
oh another talisman
go forth
become
elden lord
okay mommy can i have uh radon's armor
please
about queen america
is the vessel of the elden ring carrier
of its vision
a god in truth
but after the elton rings shattering
she was imprisoned in the earth tree
a grim punishment for shattering the
order
despite her godhood
the
technically we could
confer great runes to become elden lord
and join queen america as her consort
the fingers
have willed it so
why are the fingers so gross bro
all right we're done we're done
we're done
[Music]
okay
and
man do we want his blade or his uh his
bow too that could be fun
it only requires strength
ah i could find uh let's get this for
now we can come back and get the other
one
let the words of the fingers guide you
why would the greater will want to
replace ratagon because he
smells bad
obviously okay
let's go see what we need to do here
familia
the fingers
the fingers
god damn
god damn
hey what's up mom
it's me radon
just fat rolling out here what up mom
yo what up mom
though
i
assured of thy want
to be born anew
and you
okay let's see what we need first
so
we've got our swords we're looking we're
looking spiffy
we need 38 strength in 15 inch
in 12 decks is that even possible for us
right now i can barely move
this is so heavy
it's as fast as i could move
so let me just put points into anything
doesn't matter
because we're about to change it
oh my god we're this heavy come on
come on mommy
okay
all right do you guys remember the
numbers because i already forgot what we
need
bear this sweeting into life anew
already forgot the numbers
it was at least 12 decks i know that
we can't go down though
30 36 strength
it was 38.
it was 18 decks
i thought it was it said 12 bro
yeah it said 12.
it was 15 inch
right
18 it
endurance
oh god chat i don't think we're even
ready to do this right now
i don't we can't wear his armor that
that's for sure
oh no
20 vigor
i don't know if we want to do this yet
16.
yeah well i can just not wear his armor
but uses uh
his stuff
yeah
i think this is just too much for now
we're gonna lose out on 11 health
11 vigor
i don't think i can back out of this now
can i
cancel rebirth yes
since you weren't reborn the liberal
tier was not spent okay cool i don't
know if we want to do this yet
what the heck
this is me trying to backstep
okay okay
ronaldo's kind of sad character she's
depressed because she got her yep yep
yep
yep
yeah she's basically out of her [ __ ]
mind ronald is yeah
i would just go back and look work your
way up to it
yeah i think we gotta work our way up to
it that's uh we'll get we'll get there
we'll get there for now
it's not doable
so let's just not do it i don't want to
ruin our run either
i'm throwing these back on
we will get to it though we just can't
do it right now we need more levels
more levels
see
all right now what should we do
what should we do now
you speak to the old man in red main
after defeating radon no we can do that
let's go do that
oh i think we gotta fight these guys
oh no they're not here is there a fight
here
why are you still here
lit
okay
fia's champions are here
oh yeah we can activate the great rune
we can go see the uh
apostle
jaren
oh we could go to volcano manor as well
at last
the war festival has ended
brave champion
you have our gratitude no i didn't kill
uh the big dragon though
general radon is surely pleased i hope
so festering with rot and crippled by
madness
all he wanted
was an honorable death
yay finally
my work is done
i'm no longer bound to this fortress
i have a task in mind
old business you could say
he has something to do with selling
right
may we meet again if the fates ew
bots
hold on we're going to spin we're going
to spin we're going to spin
report
uh
that report
gone boom
then we're gonna hide
it's the maidenless bolt
sex spots oh no
okay
why on this stream it hasn't happened
the last like three streams
may we meet again if the fates
have a good one blake
okay
i wish we could see
the soldiers singing
like where are they
what are they doing
what's that
yeah we started ronnie yep
oh somber five god damn um
let's go talk to roger
yeah i know bots are a big deal on
youtube
uh youtube like streaming it's okay it's
really easy to deal with
hello pleased to meet you yo the name's
roger
but now i'm in this sorry state
i had a little mishap
potentially josh potentially as you
might guess it's far from ideal
not being fun maidenless irl this game
is fun it is oh
i know
i'm privy to a few magical battle arts
would you care to learn one time can
move rather slowly stuck here you know a
little conversation goes a long way go
where
oh god we have a lot to talk about what
can i learn
yeah i don't want to learn those right
now i've defeated godric you defeated
godric and claimed yourself a great rune
well done friend
something to yeah mark
blood stain is below stormville castle
yep that's what happened to him here
as you might have guessed i still can't
move
my fighting days are behind me
he's in a very good mood for not having
like the ability to walk anymore
he's like yeah
as lit ah
so you've met d
d is an old friend
we found ourselves journeying together
for a time
bound by our exploration of death
but our paths have since yeah right raya
gives you a talisman that makes the game
harder
for two friends
this guy is a bro
maybe i should tell you
lately
i feel i'm on the precipice precipice
fathomless slumber
sounds familiar an inkling it could
spell trouble for you somehow so i just
wanted to get the apology out of the way
beforehand since you're so scary and all
excuse me
i'm scary d was telling me
that he discovered the mark of the
centipede the centipede is an ancient
symbol of the curse mark
as long as whoever finds and uses it is
not nefarious by nature then we may be
able to form an alliance
if only i could speak to them in person
and if they were like yeah he dies on
the spot all the better
eventually
all right bye
bye
you again is it i guess
can you believe they invited me to join
them now after what they did i can
scarcely believe it myself
do they think me a fool
you might be surprised to learn i took
them up on the offer then they only had
to ask kind of them the location of the
recusant hideout
it's on mount gelmere volcano manor the
old world that leads west from the town
of windmills that's where they hide
the manor on the peak this guy's a turn
wait wretched recusants
you'll rue the day you insulted my name
by laying hands on lanyard he's gullible
is told in blood after all
yeah did roger like cuddle
uh the thing down under
god wins husk
he does defend the jars we do have to go
see the jars
um let's not do that yet
you make my stuff stronger yet no
what can we sell sell that
sell
wait
give me my runes
ew another bot eew
you guys reading that even losers [ __ ]
girls with us
the heck is that
okay
let's level up i think we got enough the
level for sure for sure for sure
i stopped it
okay love you jake
oh thank you man
thank you don for the five dollar uh
super chat thank you man
that's very very kind of you i
appreciate that
thank you
um we're gonna change all this anyway
later so that's what i
bum i'm trying to think what to do now
i'm trying to think of what to do i
think we should go to volcano manor
like that that would be the next thing i
suppose
but thank you again don
very kind of you
don do be a chat okay
um
are we we're already up here aren't we
yeah we are okay so
we helped raya which means if we go up
here she's gonna be at the top
i think
and then she'll take us to volcano manor
uh we're not quite up here yet so we can
help millicent first
what india are you going for whatever
chat wants
why is millicent not here
oh we haven't helped her we gotta go we
gotta go we gotta go
we gotta go over here
uh here
kill the noble and caleb and activate
radon's rune and i mean like don't you
guys think godzilla rune is better
then radon's rune
you want fia's ending hey if that's what
you want at the end
y'all got to be here for that though
whenever we finish this thing
i have a feeling you all are gonna
choose frenzy ending
do you think this is game of the year
absolutely so far yes there's no other
game that comes remotely close to
beating this game this year
hi
hello again
something about this place felt familiar
to me
so i decided to pay fear does have an
ending yes hoping to find someone here
but i've only found thank you your mom
perhaps
before my departure
i needed someone to say farewell to
well
never mind that
i must focus on my journey riot ending
for which i have you to thank
i must stay strong
yes well i must i must
okay now
she should go
right up her
yeah god of war ragnarok could be really
good we just don't know yet right now
this game is game of the year this is a
game of the decade for me right now what
the [ __ ] is going on with these bots
holy [ __ ]
boom gone
dead
i'm so quick with it i'm so fast
all right yep there she is
ah
we meet again
in truth it's been smooth sailing for me
the scarlet rot has stilled since last
we met as such
i've been able to continue my journey
though rather vexingly
i realized that if i still had my sword
arm
i could have aided you in battle
now i'm tracing the path melania took
after unleashing the power of the
scarlet rot
this game doesn't even come close for me
and game of the decade what does i
should like to meet her
this vanished woman i think she's in the
north
in the lands that lie beyond the earth
tree yeah we gotta do the boggart indian
don't we okay now she goes
uh i believe to windmill village correct
also we should go to the round table we
should talk to uh
corwin
you you say you're gonna leave and then
you'll be right up here
i teach incantations
the strength granted us by the two
fingers and explore the secrets of the
golden order so that one day
if a time what's happening with my audio
can you guys hear that where it like
messes up
i might cancel them don my man thank you
dude
thanks for becoming a tarnish
appreciate it man welcome welcome
do you still see it
yeah we gotta get the prosthetic as well
i do see it
wonderful news
most tarnished are blind to it these
days yeah it's really weird i don't know
why that's happening rare breed
well i mean i hear it as well
care to learn
yeah that right there you guys could
hear that right
it freaks me out
may the golden order shine through you
may the golden order shine through your
bung hole
i just destroyed that chair okay
ah i've been waiting for your return
i've decided to leave crunchy audio i
think it's the game i'm off in search of
a noble scholar known as the gold mask
to beg his instruction
we may not meet again yeah i think it's
the game if there's any incantation
what the hell man
he's bugging
may the golden order shine through you
where do we get the process we get the
prosthetic from the shaded castle right
so we need to go there too
which is near here
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i got a plan i got a plan
i gotta i gotta i'm i've got my movement
i got my path down
any kind of
you i just spit on my microphone
bowie i hate ghosts
it's got randomly hyper die
why is it happening stop it
dude should we go to volcano manor first
before all this
yeah we're doing patches questline how
do i so i've talked to patches in his
cave
how do i um
how do i continue his
i'm forgetting i'm spacing on it
all right the game is bugging
shaded castle
thanks for all the subs today too i
appreciate it
it is kind of insane that we're
over 50k now
kind of kind of nutty all right we got
to fix this don't we like what what is
happening
the game's just bugging right now
stay
yeah do i have to get transported
to the miss wood
is that like something that needs to
happen
doesn't say he's here anymore
why
you can find him in lurinia okay where
is he in lorena
i mean yeah i'll i'll let him push me
it's a it's a part of the deal you know
he's at the lake
okay we're gonna do we're gonna try this
because i don't know if can we even beat
elmer elemer
at
54.
i don't know what's going on with my
game this is weird
the audio is really bugging
hold on
here's again
here i'm going to reload this
whoa we're having some issues today i
apologize
find patches in the lake agile cave
first yes we already did that
oh we don't need to beat him we just
need the prosthetic you're right it's
right over here
you are right
see i would have gone in there and tried
to beat him i've been like oh man can't
get it
yeah welcome to life things don't go as
planned do they chat
forgetting
[Music]
eat
the next lore video should be coming out
this weekend
at some point
i did all the narration for it today i'm
going the wrong way
which is great
i'm going off
i want the world to know
there's the ladder
whoops
[Music]
and to give you guys some context of the
video i'm not going to tell you what
it's about because i don't want to ruin
anything for you
but
it took me
45 minutes
this morning just to do the voice
narration
and i didn't mess up on it very much
where i have to like re-record stuff
all right we got it
you missed
oh
camera
the final boss the camera
we're good
you think mickela is going to be the
main boss in the elden ring dlc
i have no idea they they can make so
much dlc
it's kind of unbelievable
there's so much opportunity for dlc
that it's kind of mind-boggling
you know what i mean
they can do a lot i'm not gonna fight
elmer yet i don't think that's gonna go
well if we try
i should do a poll on if you guys think
the elden beast is a good final boss
or is a good boss in general oh god
blight has confirmed a return in dlc
how do you guys know this stuff how do
you know these things
you guys smart
all right let's go give
millicent her uh
her arm
cleared all the bosses in lorena i need
to um
i need to update our boss list
i don't think we've beaten that many
bosses yet we're just kind of going
through the quest today
as many as i can and then we'll focus on
the bosses
yeah i thought the elden beast fight was
kind of meh
i wish we could use torrent why could we
not use torrent in the eldenby's fight
it would have made it so much better now
i'm tracing the path melania took
she's passed into the lands that lie
beyond the earth tree
give the prosthetis prosthesis
thank you
i am in your debt yet again
i think
if the arm serves well enough
it might be possible for me to wield a
sword again
if she arms it might be perhaps then i
can okay
now we can go this way
yeah do we have uh
we don't know we don't have nicholas
great room do we no
let's go beat uh godric over here too
or he his name isn't godric it's
something else
yeah i think the elden beast is just
there for like cinematic
uh the the like the final boss is like
uh
he's definitely ratagon he's he's a
fantastic final boss ratagon i i'd love
that fight and then it's just like a
spectacle
no
dang it
we'll have to come back
yeah godfroy
you shut up
ow
ow
yeah i don't know what they were doing
with a hundred percent or the elden
stars
i don't know what the heck that's about
it's like so obnoxious
yeah it really does because the elden
beast runs away so much
it it like
it really made me feel
that we were supposed to be there with
torrent
and it just you can't use torrent
just can't use them
no i don't think the elden beast is even
that hard i'm not saying he's a
difficult fight
but
yeah
he's just like annoying that he runs
away all the time
isn't is there not a uh place to rest
over here
there is
um do you wish that we had the chance to
fight godwin before he got all messed up
i think that's a perfect uh
future dlc thing they could do
you know
absolutely could be
okay we see raya here
raya
raya
oh i bet i have to go up here don't i
uh poopoo dude
i'm all over the place right now
do i have dexes
i'm all over the place
i don't know what i got
all right we got left we need right hoop
which is
here
bottom
wonder if multiplayer broke it well if
that's the case they could have just not
uh
you know like you can't use torrent in
multiplayer no matter what not just
because it's
the elden beast
i'm on ultra
settings i got a good graphics card
there we go
who's following me
there we go
okay we're going back
we're going back
did i give the necklace back to raya i
don't remember i need to stream more
so i can like
remember what we did
i could always go back and watch the
last stream like the last 10 minutes
then i'd probably remember
we definitely gave raya her necklace
back
if we have the invitation then we have
it
i don't see an imitation or wait it
would be
i think i'm running into a tree
okay we got it we're there
how hot is your gpu not at all it's cook
it's doing fine
it's so hard to remember
everything you do in this game it's so
difficult
which is probably why people have been
you know they're like well if we had a
quest log
we could remember
[Music]
whereas i'm just blaming my own bad
memory you know what i'm saying
it's not the game's fault my memory is
bad
keep a notebook or sticky notes for your
live stream play through
[Music]
nah
that's why i got you guys i can just ask
you and you can just
guess
it makes it more fun
what's this
you
dragon wound
greens i was so hyped
what's this guy say
it's there somewhere
another path leading back to the foot of
the earth tree in ancient tunnel oh he's
looking at the tunnel over there got it
another bot oh my god another bot oh my
god
gone
dead
ew it comes up in the chat in the top
left corner gross
[Music]
you like the belly rub idea rex i'm glad
she's getting a lot of belly rubs i
don't think we've reached 50 000 yet but
we're getting there
i gotta catch up
i do ban them it's a they're different
accounts every time
y'all need to go by the lift to find
raya i didn't see her when i went to
check just now
is it important to beat radon first
before activating this lift no
i was talking about belly rubs yoda
you don't have to be radon to activate
the lift
we just haven't gotten here yet
how many we only took two attempts on
radon right or three i think it was
three
why isn't she here the heck is she
shouldn't she be here
[Music]
what the
i wonder why she's not here that's
really weird
she should be like right here
anybody know
she had the exit from the tunnel she
tells you to go through
she's at the exit from the tunnel
she's close to where you've talked to
millicent
oh she just like changes location why is
that
yeah i'll go back over here i haven't
ever talked to her other than this area
oh she just doesn't show up now or is
she actually near here
near the grazing site behind
in the ruins back over here
okay
thank you
oh what the
what
what are you what are you doing what are
you doing i've been waiting for you
apparently you had the stuff of
champions
i hereby invite you to the volcano manor
interesting enough
and have audience with my mistress
okay give me your hand
i will pray
that you follow this thank you chat
you're very helpful
see that this is why it's more fun
to ask you guys
i wonder why she moves though it's very
very interesting
ah
oh
yeah
i love volcano manor bro
i love it here
did someone ask me earlier what the
hardest what i think the hardest souls
born boss is
that's a tough question dude
i struggled very heavily with sister
freda in uh dark souls 3 deal the first
dlc
um
i want to say lord eshen from sakiro i
would say lord eshen
might be might be the hardest and one of
my favorites
it is a healthy relationship i
appreciate it lone wolf brave tarnished
i didn't find nameless king that hard
that's just me though
he's hard though but not that hard raya
spoke well of you
a warrior of promise
i believe she said
perhaps you are prepared thanks lordy
commitment
will you join us here at the volcano
manor
and resist the tide
why accept the burden of their grace
or be fooled by the dogmatic ramblings
of the fingers
rise with us
against the earth tree
i i would think um i think melania is
the hardest boss do you guys agree with
that i think melania might be the
hardest boss in all of from software
games her or or ishin ishin the
hunchback of the volcano manor
thank you for the two dollars
s i don't know how to say your name but
but thank you
the hunchback of volcano manor
your decision is most welcome
now you belong to the volcano manor
family the drawing room lies down the
hall
make yourself comfortable
but be sure to earn your keep
okay
the drawing room is use the key i handed
you
i will
what's in here
can we have we ever been able to get in
there
you do fight her guard um when she's
consuming reichard and if you attack her
there her guard will uh attack you then
a recusant finger
look guys it's the hunchback of volcano
manor lol okay i won't make fun of her
anymore hello again brave tarnished
as a scout
i am pleased to see you again here at
the volcano manor under lady tanith's
guidance
may you tread the path of valor you know
what death bird death bird's the hardest
boss in all souls born death
under lady tanith's guidance
may you tread the path of valor
okay hey it's a boy
oh i've
it's it's you is it well nice to see you
again
so you've been invited as well i see you
as well sir
arms henceforth
sorry i am responding to
dms from multiple guys multiple really
really good looking people okay
just just to rub that in and also i'm
completely [ __ ] kidding um
let's see
no i'm not um
i was turning
turning on your stream today and i
caught this moment what is this
someone took a screenshot of my of my
stream and it when it said 69 people
watching
that's funny
little okay
guys could be guys or girls i um
i can tell you don't want dms from good
looking guys
well you see i i do after much internal
debate i've come to realize
revenge is not the answer
according to lady i'll take i'll take
messages from good looking girls as well
and champions ironic as it is are oft
forced to walk a tainted path
it hit me like a bolt from the blue that
my former thoughts were simple naivety
of course my heart weeps for lania that
unfortunate incident was a cruel twist
of fate indeed yeah y'all are thirsty
and sadness caused won't make me a
champion will it
lanya knows this i'm certain door don't
open
whatever is possible enter oh you go
from inside the walls okay thank you
by champions
uh taneth voice actress is yara greyjoy
that sounds like uh
game of thrones correct
i always resented these hands
their pale complexion
a far cry from any warriors
the shame of house oslo i think i think
melania is the glomide queen by grit
once i've set out on the path of
champions i made a video on it
is told in blood after all
i think she i think melania is a
fragment
of
the glomide queen or
the rune of death
i missed game of thrones when it was
good
game of thrones was so good
until they heaven's name are you doing
here botched it the volcano manor is a
pit of recusants who spit at grace and
hunt our own kind
i hope you understand ruin the best show
ever
well as long as you understand what
you're saying
well all right then
by virtue
perhaps playing that part led you to
your doubts i wonder
but know that the path you walk is
blasphemous i think the glow my queen is
ronnie's teacher
you mean before you consider hunting any
of your own kind
think on that
[Music]
you guys like that
i won't do it again sorry
[Music]
well technically we could go right to
reichardt if we want to
but is that something we want to do
familia did you read the letter left for
you that is the task the volcano manor
desires you enact favorite game of
thrones episode
i think jon snow is my favorite
character
so be it
but you must leave this house at once
this is a war against the earth tree
i'll do it no place for the meat
your mom's me
i would say my favorite episode in game
of thrones is when the church exploded
that that was some of the best tv i've
ever seen
are you doing playing this amazing game
i'm always doing good when i'm playing
elden ring you know
right guys
all right guys okay let's go let's go in
the volcano manor
now right card reichard is extremely
easy
however we're gonna ruin uh a bit of a
quest line
his quest line
you
if i beat reichard now so i don't want
to fight him yet
however
i could start the killing i could start
the uh the assassinations
might as well do that
i can do two of them and then i'll have
to wait on the last one
what's your favorite questline in the
game
[Music]
i like millicent's questline a lot
i think hers is cool
i don't know if it's my favorite though
i'd have to think about that one
yeah the cersei plot
and the church oh my god
so good
oh oh oh oh oh oh we're we're going to
do this and then we're going to um go to
wherever you you guys told me patches
was in laurenia right
we got we need to find him next
i i think this game will win game of the
year um depending on
i think ragnarok could be that as well
but we're just not sure
some radon [ __ ] bro
this is my game of the year even if uh
god of war is good
i'm i'm going to go ahead and guess that
uh
ragnarok will be great
can't stagger him huh
there's our bleed that we want frig i'm
too far away
and
you're dead
he's there is a merchant
okay
where in durania though that's this is
going to be this is where this is hard
to do with the with the chat room
is this this [ __ ] heavy yeah okay
favorite armor set
uh the hunters outfit in bloodborne
thank you for everything you do sir
continue to inspire the uninspired
encourages myself and others to keep
going keep being amazing and never
forget you are a truly incredible
wonderful and amazing human being much
love
that's the nicest message i've ever
received in my life thank you oh my god
and that was a 101
donation i thought it was ten dollars in
one cent that is a hundred and one
dollar donation
holy crap
that is big
dude thank you so much
decorius
get some hype in the chat for that man
oh my god that's out of nowhere
dude thank you so much wow
with the nicest message i've ever gotten
oh wow
thank you man that is super nice of you
so nice of you thank you man
wow
oh i gotta stop for that one for a
second my god
thank you dude much love much love bro
we'll keep it going we'll keep it going
i really really appreciate that
you guys are still gonna have to tell me
where patches is because i've never seen
them out here
i got kicked somewhere near volcano
manor and that's the extent of patches
that i know
thank you bro you are that is over the
top kind for real thank you
the soulsborne community is much more
friendly than people at on uh i think
it's i think it's always known that
they've been friendly um
you guys let me know if you think this
or not i think the pvp
community
is not friendly
i think the soulsborne community itself
is great and very kind and helping but
the uh the pvp side of it is a little uh
little uh little out there you know you
should be a volcano manor now
after you accepted volcano manor invite
okay
no thank you man i'm just i'm just
making videos and hope people enjoy them
so any any extra support like that is is
greatly appreciated it helps me out a
ton thank you man
yeah i just think multiplayer gaming is
kind of toxic in in general yeah it's
probably a better way to put it
okay
he's on an island south of the crab
shack west of rise initial location okay
i want to know where this is just for me
um
so help me out here
help me out raya should be
this is the shack and you said it's to
the south of the shack right
so we'll go here
latest video is really good i i thought
it was time to kind of you know just
because we hit 50 000 subscribers
i thought it was um
i thought it was it was time to talk
about me uh just a little bit like i'm
not gonna do that very often but
um obviously i will in the streams but
i thought i thought it was it was time
for that so
i'm glad you guys liked it
it's it it's an interesting story
southwest
yeah even if he's not here that's okay
he's on a ruin
would i be able to see it on the map
is he in these woods here
i like all music except country
i think i've gone too far
near a rock you just passed
i don't want to mess with those guys
yeah that's kind of the basis
wait
oh you growled at me
nerd
yeah that was kind of the basis of the
whole video
is that it gets better
things may be bad it gets better
i'm lost
any specific artist
um
i would say i listen to foo fighters and
tool the most
like right now
i am a big fan of the foo fighters
all right i'm hitting this thing up here
yeah i'm just not a fan of country
myself i don't mind it though like i
would go to a country concert i just
wouldn't enjoy it as a different one
you slightly prefer this
over uh bloodborne
yeah bloodborne is uh
is [ __ ] incredible it's just quite
different from this game
it's a totally different uh experience
all right
that's where patches would be so he
would be here
okay i don't think he is
okay thank you
now i know
but we're gonna leave
he should be up at volcano manor now
which
we need to go
when you go here we need to talk to
corwin and everything yeah this this is
the way to go okay thank you chad you're
very helpful
has there ever been a game or movie that
made you cry oh god yeah
of course
i'm a little [ __ ]
dude when it comes to like stories like
sad stories i'm i'm a crying little baby
uh last of us made me cry
um i can't think of any other games but
there's been tons of movies that have
made me cry
of course
who's corwin we're about to see him
he's one of my least favorite characters
in this game along with gold
mask we need to do
oh yeah dude gears of war
yup
true why gold masks i just i just don't
like their quest line that much look who
we have here
how delightful to meet uh flame of
frenzy's my favorite ending
the round table hold
i've been doing some learning of my own
since then favorite movie
honestly right now it's the new batman
um i love goodfellas
right now it's the new batman
big fan of goodfellas um
yeah it's either that or good fellas
i'm yet to find the noble gold mask
i suppose he'll be closer to the earth
tree the path ahead might be perilous
hey but tread it i shall can you help me
since departing the round table hold
i've come to understand in my solitude
how little it is i truly know
i'm yet to find the noble goldness
get out of here
yeah i really like um
i really like mafia movies so good
fellas i i know a lot of people griped
on the irishman for how like long it was
but i'm i love the irishman um
there's so many
godfather godfather all the godfathers
um
yeah
i was a huge fan of the dark knight i
think the newer batman
is better
in its own ways
oh yeah
the new batman in my opinion is great i
i really enjoyed it
it's quite long though
i
terribly sorry uh are you here as a
customer
you're right lone wolf i i just didn't
enjoy doing it i guess i should preface
there
what do you have i need these
thanks
ah i must apologize
the depart it's a great movie that true
great movie
very true
yeah inner uh
talking about christopher nolan
interstellar probably up there in one of
my favorite movies ever
interstellar was just stupidly good
[Music]
inception's a great movie yep
you guys seen shutter island another
really good movie with leonardo dicaprio
shutter island's awesome
lion king 1994 best movie all time
changed my mind you could be right man i
don't need to change your mind on that
one
all right we found gold mass now we need
to go back to our boy over her
what's your favorite demon eldon souls
born akira boss theme
what's a boss theme
my favorite boss ever is lord eshen from
sakiro
kill the irishman no i haven't seen that
green knight
no i don't think i've seen that
i forget names of movies really easily
though
ah
you appear to be doing well
very good
well then
would you like to learn an incantation
you believe that the 10 minutes here on
earth thing was [ __ ] no that's
actually a real thing like time can be
warped based on your
you know like
it's all about distance right something
like that
do you sport with me sport your
description
it can be no other than the gold mask
himself you have a favorite game my
favorite game ever is sly cooper 2 band
of
thieves the golden order
is benevolent my favorite game ever and
that'll never change
my sincerest thanks
may the golden order shine i'm ignorant
about that one that's just my that's my
[ __ ] i love that game
to death
sly cooper baby
go back here probably should have got a
side there's a side of grace like right
below the bridge over here
yeah it's gravity right
i need to watch the movie again
the batmobile in the new batman is my
favorite batmobile it's sick it's like a
muscle car
i'm gonna try and jump on his head
dang it
ah we meet yet again
thanks to you i have become acquainted
with the noble gold mask himself no i
haven't seen that song he's by his side
as you can see that's very cool
i will still teach you incantations as
before
though we must do so quietly
come on everybody had an invitation if
you've played sly cooper you had a you
had a crush on carmelita fox
if you've played sly cooper you 100 had
a crush on the carmelita fox
so of course i did
while i frantically attempt to record
his wisdom
the movement of his finger
and though i am yet to comprehend even
the daintiest morsel of his wisdom he is
so tall
this is my life's calling the golden
order has bestowed me
talentless as i am
the great duty of documentarian
yes you can meet corin at the end of the
game in the ashen
capital city yes
the golden order i heard the audio thing
again it scared me okay
you speak now
he's so skinny
he's so skinny okay
yeah he does look like he's made of
stone somewhat right
like an all buster
can we see his face like if i zoom
oh wait i can just do this
it's like what the heck's going on here
what is this
that didn't help and it turns off when i
turn this on
he's blind he ain't got no eyeballs
this man dead
i don't know what's going on there
dailon thank you for becoming a tarnish
man
i appreciate
that very kind of you no the audio all
right i know what to do now though but
thank you man i appreciate it welcome
welcome welcome
good to have you
i know what to do okay it's gonna make
that weird sound again so hold on
okay we should be good now
thanks again dylon welcome
to the tarnished
all right
let's go let's go let's go
millicent uh should be up here right
we gotta beat the gold mask or not the
not the gold mask the uh
apostle
yeah it can't be an almonoric since he
has legs
so he's not that
i didn't fix the problem i thought i did
i did not
that is an issue
might be the game chat i don't know
favorite place in eldon ring obviously
here
i mean just look at how fun it is and
how the sky just changes to darkness
every time i come here
like look at this face
can't get enough of that
you guys ever seen mid-summer
if you haven't seen midsummer
go watch it and this will make more
sense
the audio is really pissing me off
i think they're newman
no i don't think they're newman they
could be
don't know that for sure though
hey yo what up bro
bush
[Music]
ow
oh the audio is so bad why does that
happen dude
ow
stop
it hurts my ears
oh that would have been a horrific
ending
yeah
yep it's a bug it's not my fault
i just want to say i've really been
enjoying your videos and appreciated
hearing your journey of content creation
in one of your latest videos i'm really
glad you enjoyed it man thank you for
watching it
i gotta fix this audio thing man it's
bothering me it hurts my ears
might have something to do with obs okay
hold on
hold
okay
if i'm if i'm right on this it's gonna
make the sound again
okay hopefully it won't make that sound
now
because that just is not nice
millicent
got you got a non-bitchy group
no i am currently single and not looking
at all
not dating in the slightest ah
we meet yet again
nice dude
i wish i could hear you millicent
even handling a sword
perhaps it is foolish to say this to you
of all people
but i am sure of my skill with the sword
thus
i would have you call upon me oh i'm
sorry melissa should you ever have the
need
i
which from what i've been told by
everybody right yeah i'm gonna restart
the game because that is uh that is
bothering me from what i have been told
um
whenever you stop looking for you know
your girlfriend your potential like
dating you know whoever right
is apparently
when
that person shows up so like right when
you stop looking is when is when it'll
happen
so i am just being
patient and calm and just kind of like
waiting for whatever comes my way you
know
like if someone that i liked asked me on
a date i wouldn't say no
so i shouldn't say that i'm like not
looking
but
you know
yeah once you stop tryharding it hap it
just like happens
so
maybe that'll be the case for me i have
no idea
i'm just doing my thing right
now and it's been nice
hopped around for a bit and then gave up
boom got my current girlfriend who i've
been with for six years that's what i'm
saying dude like i had i had my
girlfriends uh
i had a long-term girlfriend you know i
talked about it in the video like
i went i went through my whole face okay
and i'm i'm too old to be a hoe anymore
so now i'm just like doing my thing
i think we all go through a whole phase
at one time or another
that's how my girlfriend and i met she
was not looking to date and then i came
crashing into her life
wasn't trying at all when i met danielle
exactly exactly trey
so that's that's what i mean hey she's
already gone okay
[Music]
i'm 27. it said that my uh
my audience is like around my age as
well so that's kind of nice
whereas on twitch i was pretty much
babysitting kids so it's kind of nice to
be here now
would you rather have your mom as
america or ranala well renault is insane
i would say ranala
i don't know though
depends
yeah you guys are like in your 20s i
would assume maybe some of you aren't
but that's fine
awesome man your voice is super pleasant
too that's thank you bag of tricks
that's very nice
i'm 12 band that guy
just kidding i don't can't like prove
that okay
millicent should go
to
way uh way up top now right
yes
all right let's take uh let's not do i
don't think we're gonna look at our boss
list today but i will go through the
video and update it
because i'm way too far behind now
interested in making videos for elden
ring but don't really know where to
start lore gameplay challenges should i
pick something and go for it
um yes also you can never go wrong wrong
with uh like education right so
when i started making elden ring videos
it was like how to do stuff
like how to beat a certain boss or um
how to get a certain item
armor sets swords stuff like that and
then i just took a shot in the dark with
a with a lore video and it did really
well and now and then i just didn't stop
so yeah just
pick something that you want to do and
you'll be fine
you're just doing a level one challenge
play through i tried doing that and from
what i've been told it's not worth so
i'm just not gonna do it
i prefer just having fun playing elden
ring
so whether that is that doesn't
necessarily mean that i need to have
like a major challenge right
so
i'm just playing the game having a good
time
i don't need things to be hard to enjoy
it
that's for me though
i need that
i was like no shot you can launch it
that short hold it
ironic
timing
timing
yeah how to dodge melania's waterfowl
dance i'm sure that's all over
already
what have you done today
we beat radon that's kind of the main
thing
right we've kind of done a lot we're
just doing uh i'm mainly focused on
quests today
quests
godfrey loved morgot at least he did
i think so
pve lore inspired build videos
how would you do that
that's an interesting idea
so like pvp
characters based on lore that's very
cool
i see
uh-huh
i know how to fight you now margaret
i [ __ ] up
oh that
these delayed ass swings man
you're such a trickster
yeah my dodges were good now they're
not are you backing up bro you scared
huh you scared
well beat you why are you backing up man
huh
he's scared dude
what is he doing
what you doing
you're just going back in your spot
i gotta dodge in there bro
oh wouldn't let me move for a second
i don't feel like that should have hit
me but it did
whoa whoa hey
felt like that might have been unfair
i'm stuck in a crater oh god it's over
why is this way harder than usual
okay
it's the hardest boss i've faced
can't get him to bleed
okay dude
finally
yeah i don't understand the terrain here
you get stuck in craters pretty much
that sounds nice put that on
gg that was tough though oh my god
i think uh melania says uh some
important dialogue up here that i'm
gonna pop on
[Music]
yeah the move with the hammer is cool i
i like that one
yeah so when we fight them on the bridge
and here they're just illusions of
morgots
called markets
remember when i first encountered market
as a samurai i didn't get the summoning
bell or i i didn't summon roger and i
beat him first try i call it the souls
fan effect
probably man this sounds like you're
good at the game
sounds like you're just a legend
oh wait i should uh
no it's not all items and summons i
should get these uh golden seeds down
here as well
nerd
yeah he uses the bodies of like
commoners
why did they give you so many golden
seeds up here
and i've got ronnie's ending is it worth
playing two more runs to get the three
ending trophies
heck yeah it is
am i still gonna get attacked
yup
that answers that question ow
[Music]
stay up there
i'm not fighting those guys either
well i will eventually but all right now
right now
okay okay okay
i think we're good there blah blah blah
bada bing bada boom little bit of baba
dabba you know what i'm sayin
grab this
now we gotta go fight the draconic tree
sentinel
and then uh all i want to do is open
this up i don't want to go into the city
yet i want to uh find
patches which should be volcano near
volcano manor correct
where he kicks you
[Music]
i'm sad how there's a maximum of flash
charges
uh they don't want people to be 20.
the serpent king family or the marilyn
manson family
i'll take together
as family
together as family
please take me to the earth tree i need
to burn down tree yeah not the earth
tree just a tree well a branch really
yes
indeed
oh
that kind of hurt
whoa
okay bro
and we're getting botted i don't know if
i can beat that guy yet
that's uh that's a tough one dude
uh oh guys
three sex
three sex
i i wonder
[Music]
does that work
do people click on that
i really hope none of you click on that
it's pretty clearly a bot
all right this can be tough
yeah get the bleed down
that couldn't have gone better
how how
okay
okay
ah this ain't worth it
nope uh we're gonna we're gonna come
back here guys we're gonna grab our
runes and we're gonna come back this is
we are not strong enough for this yet we
need to go to volcano manor that's
that's what we need to do
oh man that is rough
i got bonked dude
uh
i pretty much already made a video on
that yoda
watch the video called like father like
son
excuse excuse me
fight the death bird
that sounds terrible
that sounds awful
do not want to do that
when do you think dlc is going to come
out
whenever they're done because i'm not
sure
lucaria
what are you looking at hey shut up
you again is it
perfect bloody time and actually
i got crab
cooked up fresh
he's got the crab
you should probably know
there's something i should probably tell
you you heard of the dunk eater he's a
man
has it out for everyone
curses him
goes around in his rank armor and all
you see him though
do you say america's tits well away
i was in the same jail as him once so i
know firsthand
he's a god forsaken monster
not just some petty dog like me
yeah my first time fighting that
draconic tree sentinel i think took me
two hours
and i think i screamed in joy
i love getting attacked by a bug while
i'm eating he's a killer
kills people
and curses the souls does all sort of
[ __ ] to the corpses
to keep him cursed forever i ain't seen
nothing more disgusting in all my ears
i've never been more scared neither
rooted to the bloody spot
while he did that
to my friend
oh my god
that's sad i might buy some crab
never met someone with a taste for crab
i couldn't trust
you've got a real thing here eh
and it's only getting better
ow
piss off
america's tits
you must be hungry there it is boys
america's tits
okay so
i have to pee
i'm gonna go pee real quick i will be
right back
enjoy uh
our man here
up some crap oh god i [ __ ] up
i'll be right back
brb
[Music]
america's tits
oh okay everyone get everyone go to the
bathroom
we gotta wait for your mom
all right
hold on checking checking phone checking
phone i am checking my phone
just real quick sometimes you know you
gotta gotta check and see if uh anything
is going on
okay
well i think we should do
volcano manor for one
yes that's what we should do
oh [ __ ] forgot about patches did that
say patches was in here
no i have not watched morbius i've seen
everyone talking about it
who's in bernal taneth right night
dielos okay
never mind we're gonna go
well
we need to come in from this way but we
can't be down in the shaded castle so
we'll go here we'll go around
we'll be good i wanted to see what dung
eater did when you let him out but i
couldn't bring myself to get this poor
guy killed by him
yeah well
you'll see it here
morbid time
is it a good show or are people just
memeing it
favorite elden ring ost
godskin
uh
elden beast
those are my three faves
it's [ __ ] terrible
why is everyone talking about it then
what the heck
ignore that guy for now
for now
for now
nerd
oh
what up mike
best thing to come out way better than
the new batman movie that's a troll
souls 3 ost
i do like vort vort's very cool
i don't know i really like the abyss
watchers
what is that
i love the new batman movie it's one of
my favorite movies
oh yeah
yeah we're ignoring that for now we will
come back if need be
rip deer
rip goat
rip goat
okay
it's over here right here i don't wanna
let me get this over here first
yeah if you got kidnapped a volcano
manor that's probably not gonna be your
best experience
robert pattinson wishes he could be morb
i'll just plateau
god
it over here am i too uh too early
i can always come back up
oh wait i'm too early i'm definitely too
early i know where to go now
yep
i remember
now brave
tarnished
smoldering with thy meager flame
cower
in fear
of the night
the hands of the fell omen shall proof
thee no quarter
i played this game way too [ __ ] much
close one keep climbing
okay we're good
put
these foolish ambitions to rest
no i haven't collected any death roots
yet that can be done pretty much at any
point
dude do you know what my character looks
like
giga chad
you think i need to look like morb
i'm gigga chad
you kidding me bro
ooh we're heavy
can't do that
[Music]
what a getup
dang it
gigga chat there we go now we look cool
true giga wouldn't wear armor
all right
who wants me to be naked
do you think eating is a hobby no it's a
necessity
in moderation
is that enough
oh
i can get some runes right here
did it just lag again
i have to see what's going on
take me out to dinner
well if you insist
elon musk fat roll loadout
what is that
all right he is over to the left over
here if i remember right
near this guy
let me kill this guy though
can you at least do a more build
you can do a more build
is 100 even possible i don't know but
we're gonna find out
he was right here right we're close to
here
[Music]
i don't see any glowstone
or rainbow stones
patches is hard to find
oh my god
welcome back octopus
there we go
thank you your mom
you have to do this before doing
something volcano manor which tells you
in his dialogue not to he tells you in
his dialogue not to go to volcano manor
dang it
i did join before i talked to him didn't
i
why is this happening your stream it
happens to
everything happens to every stream
it's like a problem
i'm not afraid to summon i'll summon
i'll summon as many people as i freaking
want bro
no pants run
damn
before the falling stop star beast isn't
that where we are
yeah it should be right here but he's
not
here
worst boss in any game
pinwheel dark souls one
oh you ain't here boys
and girls
yeah we're leveling up to eventually use
radon stuff i am not fighting this thing
nope
or a bed of chaos that's a better answer
better chaos
i would eat thy two fingers for
breakfast
breakfast
no i don't think he's in limb grave cave
because um
when i checked the map his uh thing
wasn't there
can't check right now oh the manor looks
so ominous
we can survive patches is kick but we
can't survive five feet
yes i would consider that
moderation melissa ah
welcome
yes right this way
right this way let me just stand in your
fire thank you sir welcome
valued customer
come
trade in
our wandering emporium
please
buy something
i'm hungry
i've been hungry so long i'm hungry
please
the fall damage is extremely
inconsistent but
that's life welcome to life
i didn't buy anything
i'm hungry
please
i'm
so hungry
all right
next time i see patches i say we murder
them thoughts
it'll be a 99 playthrough
and that's just because patches is a
giant meme in all of these games
he is a memeer
and a traitor in a big stupid poopoo
head
i say we murder him
kick him off a ledge
we'll see he could be in the manor we
will check
god damn
one day i will look just like this in
real life
he only gives you a candle stick
yeah and he also doesn't help us in our
fight at all with regan he just pieces
out like a little weenie hut jr
alright what do you think did we fight
this guy
um
with two katanas bro
[Applause]
boy i'm putting i'm putting stuff on i'm
sorry
oh god
this is just the bowl from sakiro dude
it's the bowl from sakiro
that's all you are
i hate this i hate this fight
i need a blunt weapon
which is not what i'm using
same worth
ow
he's in the ground
my dodges are
perfect i'm consistently hitting it
never mind
scratch everything i just said
and i we barely
scratched the surface on this guy
nope
nope
nope
why did i do that i don't have any mana
time to go
time to go
that's a nope
that's a nope
we'll come back
we'll be back
the morbius build eats this boss for
breakfast
uh all i know is katanas aren't very
good against that
no i definitely don't need a mimic i
need a blunt weapon
the show for show is patches in here
hey
it's our boy
it's our boy well you joined the manorah
i don't believe it
didn't think you had it in you
and here i thought raya was barking up
the wrong tree
all good though we're on the same side
now
we'll do good work together
oh and of course we can do business if
you like
we need the morbius great room
especially for you what's up thirsty
what's up mason
about patches are you surprised that i
belong to the volcano manor no not at
all he's hated the gibberish about lost
grace and the laughable two fingers
i thought i could lend a hand in
unmasking the charade i won't kill him
today bro
bugging dude
what can we get from him
oh we can buy margaret's shackle that we
don't need anymore lol um well we can
fight morgot with it the parrying dagger
is cool
uh
yeah you're kind of whatever aren't you
bro okay let me sell anything if i got
it dude which i do not alright lit lit
go cheers yourself anything
else something on your shopping list no
no trouble nope all right cheers for
that
all right what do i do with him next
do i do i mention him to tanith or
something
300k subs at the end of the year
you think so
that'd be neat i would like that
the goal is 100k you've completed your
task yes i did i am pleased i know now
you are a recusant
and a full-fledged member of the volcano
this is your award
as promised
magma shot never forget
that they're accusing the fighters
that's what she said of the champion
but for this very reason
it is the true path to valor i'm glad
you liked the video oh gee
thank you for watching it
now you are a request i am pleased okay
let's do the next one there should be
the guy in the hallway now yep
have a good one yoda someone please kill
him
that horrendous serpent
peter reichard
hmm
you're tarnished
here to put the demi-gods to the sword
then please
kill the great serpent
unfortunately i can't unless you guys
just don't care
about the bernal quest
which no we gotta do it
brandish the spear and run him through
the great serpent
that
unspeakable monstrosity
prayed they were reduced to gluttonous
depravity
once he gave himself to the serpent
whatever that thing is
it is no longer prater reichard
someone
must
okay
[Music]
he pressed two
it's you is it i'm terribly sorry but
would you mind giving me some time to
myself
i haven't cheated anything at all thus
far
even though i've dirtied my hands all
right man
i'm still yet come back later
yeah you keep telling me what to do and
it's kind of annoying it's worse than
that
as things stand i've given up on the
path of revenge and sullied the name of
my house what an easy mark i must have
been
how did it take me so long to realize
honestly there's just no end to my
foolishness is there
now i'm hungry melissa
perhaps i am a fool after all
no
it's worse than that
as things stand
i've given up on the path of revenge and
sullied the name of my house
what does pr crater mean uh it's his
name i think it does mean something
though right
perhaps i am a fool no
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay okay okay
whatever have you ever
heard
any strange sounds here at the manor
something beyond the walls
like uh no this is i've beaten this game
many many many times oh fine what am i
saying
it just is impossible i must be tired
i've be i have like 300 hours
i i think i just hit 300 hours like this
week
okay now we need to go in here
means rank
okay okay
there we go
snail
dead snail
dead
snails
wait
all right
got a bloodhound [ __ ] down here
not fun to fight
okay
that worries me every time
would call me a master
hey jake do you think sony will make a
morbid
you guys really like morbius huh
they offer some pretty cool elden bling
in exchange for whacking my friends and
that's good enough for me
oh you mean the volcano manor yeah dude
heck yeah man
oh we're here baby we're here
is that blind in the skies no
this is a really cool area
okay
we can kind of just get through it
really quick
and get to the bridge
i'm either debating on running through
here or being done for the day and
picking up here another time
i think this is a good place to call it
because i can't play for much longer and
i don't think i can yeah
this is a good place to call it i think
yeah i'm still thinking
yeah i gotta leave and like
30 minutes
yeah i can't play anymore guys
we gotta get off for the day
we gotta get off for the day
okay
boys
and girls
i appreciate every single one of you for
being here i had a great time i always
loved streaming here on youtube it's
always super fun
appreciate all the support just hit 50
000 subscribers it's kind of insane
can't it's still kind of hard to believe
in my brain
um
you know thanks for all the new
memberships today the donations super
chats everything man everything helps it
really does and i i really really really
[ __ ] appreciate it
we've got a new lore video coming out
more than likely tomorrow or sunday
i finished all the writing and i did all
the narration today it's all it's my
longest video yet so we'll see how that
goes um
i think it's really good
um
next thing i'll say is if you guys want
to watch the video early
check the description you can join my
patreon if you want early access to all
youtube videos with no ads that's
totally up to you it's just another way
to
give you some benefits as well um and
also helping me out
there too
totally up to you if you want to
appreciate it thank you for hanging out
regardless guys are great
and i will see you all
very soon i i i'll probably be streaming
either another time this weekend or
really early in the week next week so
i'll see y'all then thank you all again
have a great rest of your day great
night and i'll see you again soon thanks
again